[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this
[Music]
my
[Music]
do
[Music]
good afternoon at the federal reserve
we are strongly committed to achieving
the monetary policy goals that congress
has given us maximum employment and
price stability
since the beginning of the pandemic we
have taken forceful actions to provide
some relief and stability
to ensure that the recovery will be as
strong as possible
and to limit lasting damage to the
economy
today my colleagues on the federal open
market committee and i
made some important changes to our
policy statement
including an update to our guidance for
the likely path of our policy interest
rate
guided by our new statement on
longer-run goals and monetary policy
strategy that we announced a few weeks
ago these changes clarify our strong
commitment
over a longer time horizon
before describing today's policy actions
let me briefly review
recent economic developments
economic activity has picked up from its
depressed second quarter level
when much of the economy was shut down
to stem the spread of the virus
with the reopening of many businesses in
factories and fewer people withdrawing
from social interactions
household spending looks to have
recovered about three quarters of its
earlier decline
nonetheless spending on services that
typically require people to gather
closely
including travel and hospitality is
still quite weak
the recovery in household spending also
likely owes to federal stimulus
stimulus payments and expanded
unemployment benefits
which provided substantial and timely
support to household incomes
activity in the housing sector has
returned to its level at the beginning
of the year
and we are starting to see signs of an
improvement in business investment
the recovery has progressed more quickly
than generally expected
and forecasts from fomc participants for
economic growth this year
have been revised up since our june
summary of economic projections
even so overall activity remains well
below its level before the pandemic
and the path ahead remains highly
uncertain
in the labor market roughly half of the
22 million jobs that were lost in march
and april
have been regained as many people
returned to work
the unemployment rate declined over the
past four months but remains
elevated at 8.4 percent as of august
although we welcome this progress we
will not lose sight of the millions of
americans who remain out of work
looking ahead fomc participants project
the unemployment rate to continue to
decline
the median projection is 7.6 at the end
of this year
5.5 next year and four percent by 2023
the economic downturn has not fallen
equally on all americans
and those least able to shoulder the
burden have been hardest hit
in particular the high level of
joblessness has been especially severe
for
lower wage workers in the services
sector for women
and for african-americans and hispanics
the economic dislocation has upended
many lives and created
great uncertainty about the future
the pandemic has also left a significant
imprint on inflation
for some goods including food supply
constraints have led to notably higher
prices
adding to the burden for those
struggling with lost income
more broadly however weaker demand
especially in sectors that have been
most affected by the pandemic has held
down consumer prices
and overall inflation is running well
below our two percent longer run
objective
the median inflation projection from
fomc participants
rises from one point two percent this
year to one point
seven percent next year and reaches two
percent
in two thousand twenty three as the
economy began its recovery
coveted 19 cases hospitalizations and
deaths
also rose the reimposition of some
social distancing restrictions as well
as more cautious behavior by many
individuals
have succeeded in slowing the spread of
the virus
as we have emphasized throughout the
pandemic the outlook for the economy is
extraordinarily uncertain and will
depend in large part
on our success in keeping the virus in
check
all of us have a role to play in our
nation's response to the pandemic
following the advice of public health
professionals to keep appropriate social
distances and to wear masks in public
will help get the economy back to full
strength
a full economic recovery is unlikely
until people are confident
that it is safe to re-engage in a broad
range of activities
the path forward will also depend on the
policy actions taken across all parts of
the government to provide relief and to
support the recovery for as long as
needed
the federal reserve's response to this
crisis has been guided by our mandate to
promote maximum employment
and stable prices for the american
people along with our responsibilities
to promote the stability of the
financial system
we remain committed to using our full
range of tools to support the economy in
this challenging time
the changes we made in today's policy
statement reflect our strategy to
achieve
our dual mandate goals by seeking to
eliminate shortfalls from maximum
employment
and achieve inflation that averages two
percent over time
as we articulated in our statement on
longer-run goals and monetary policy
strategy
we view maximum employment as a
broad-based and inclusive goal and did
not see
a high level of employment as posing a
policy concern
unless accompanied by signs of unwanted
increases in inflation
or the emergence of other risks that
could impede the attainment of our goals
and we believe that achieving inflation
that averages two percent over time
helps ensure that longer term inflation
expectations remain well anchored at our
longer run
two percent objective
in turn well-anchored inflation
expectations enhance our ability to meet
both our employment and inflation
objectives
particularly in the new normal in which
interest rates are closer to their
effective lower bound
even in good times hence as we say in
our statement
with inflation running persistently
below two percent
we will aim to achieve inflation
moderately above two percent for some
time
so that inflation averages two percent
over time
and longer term inflation expectations
remain well anchored at two percent
we expect to maintain an accommodative
stance of monetary policy until these
outcomes
including maximum employment are
achieved
with regard to interest rates we now
indicate that we expect it will be
appropriate
to maintain the current zero to one
quarter percent target range for the
federal funds rate
until labor market conditions have
reached levels levels consistent with
the committee's assessments of maximum
employment
and inflation has risen to two percent
and is on track to moderately exceed two
percent for some time
in addition over coming months we will
continue to
increase our holdings of treasury
securities and agency mortgage-backed
securities
at least at the current pace these asset
purchases are intended to sustain
smooth market functioning and help
foster accommodative financial
conditions
thereby supporting the flow of credit to
households and businesses
we believe the strong policy guidance we
are providing today will serve the
economy well
by promoting our goals through the many
possible paths the recovery may take
of course as we note in our policy
statement we would be prepared to adjust
the stance of monetary policy
as appropriate if risks emerge that
could impede the attainment of our goals
the federal reserve has also been taking
broad and forceful actions to more
directly support the flow of credit in
the economy for households
for businesses large and small and for
state and local governments
preserving the flow of credit is
essential for mitigating the damage to
the economy and promoting a robust
recovery many of our programs rely on
emergency lending powers that require
the support of the treasury department
and are available only
in very unusual circumstances such as
those we find ourselves in today
these programs serve as a backstop to
key credit markets and appear to have
restored the flow of credit from private
lenders
through normal channels we have deployed
these lending powers to an unprecedented
extent
enabled in large part by financial
backing and support from congress
and the treasury when the time comes
after the crisis has passed we will put
these emergency tools
back in the toolbox as i've emphasized
before
these are lending powers not spending
powers the fed cannot grant money to
particular beneficiaries
we can only create programs or
facilities with broad-based
eligibility to make loans to solvent
entities
with the expectation that the loans will
be repaid
many borrowers are benefiting benefiting
from these programs as is the overall
economy
but for many others getting a loan that
may be difficult to repay
may not be the answer in these cases
direct fiscal support may be needed
elected officials have the power to tax
and spend and to make decisions about
where we
as a society should direct our
collective resources
the fiscal policy actions that have been
taken thus far have made a critical
difference to families businesses
and community communities across the
country
even so the current economic downturn is
the most severe in our lifetimes
it will take a while to get back to the
levels of economic activity and
employment
that prevailed at the beginning of this
year and it may take continued support
from both monetary and fiscal policy to
achieve that
we understand that our actions affect
communities families and businesses
across the country everything we do is
in service to our public mission
we are committed to using our full range
of tools to support the economy and to
help assure
that the recovery from this difficult
period will be
as robust as possible
finally i would like to take a moment to
recognize the passing of our friend and
colleague
thomas laubach his outstanding analysis
and advice have been indispensable to
the fomc
and have played a key role in the policy
decisions that will define
this era of the federal reserve he will
be remembered
for his intellect but also his kindness
his equanimity
and his dedication to achieving our
mission on behalf of the american people
we will miss him thank you i'll now be
glad to take your questions
thank you nick timmers
uh good afternoon uh chair powell nick
tamaras from the wall street journal
uh you've been very clear about the
committee's intentions on rates
not even thinking about thinking about
raising rates
and today showing low rates even as
unemployment falls to four percent
and inflation rises to two percent my
question is about asset purchases
does the guidance today apply to the
current
asset purchase piece are there any
macroeconomic conditions under which you
would favor
increasing the monthly pace of treasury
and mbs purchases
and under what conditions would a
decrease in the monthly
pace of purchases be appropriate thank
you
thank you thank you so we say in our
post-meeting statement that will
continue to
increase our securities holdings at
least at the current pace over coming
months to sustain
smooth market functioning and help
foster combinative financial conditions
that latter part is an updating of our
guidance to reflect
um what i've been saying in these press
conferences for some time and what other
central banks have
acknowledged which is that the purchases
are uh fostering accommodated financial
conditions as well
that that amounts to roughly 80 billion
a month of treasuries and 40 billion
net per month for mbs so we do we do
think that these purchases have been
effective in in
in restoring or early market conditions
and have supported the flow of credit to
households and businesses including by
fostering more accommodated financial
conditions which of course
we think is a good thing so um
in terms of going forward i would just
say this there are
various ways and margins that we can
adjust our tools going forward
and we'll continue to monitor
developments and we're prepared to
adjust our plans as appropriate
if i could follow up i suppose the
question i have is why give guidance on
one policy tool
but not give guidance on the other
policy tool when the fed has talked
about those two policy tools
working together so we think our pro
we think our policy stance is
appropriate today and we're prepared to
adjust it going forward as we as
we we see appropriate and today we
believe that uh particularly this very
strong
forward guidance very powerful
forwarding forward guidance that we've
announced today
will provide strong support for the
economy effectively we're saying that
race will remain highly accommodative
until the economy is far along in its
recovery and that that should be a very
powerful statement in supporting
economic activity
now we're buying uh 120 billion in
securities per month
across the across the treasury curve
that's also adding to
uh accommodation we do have the
flexibility to adjust that tool and
and the rate tool and and other tools as
well but as for right now we think uh we
think that our policy setting is
appropriate to support
uh the expansion we did we said from the
beginning that we would first
uh try to provide um some uh
uh support and stability and relief
in the first phase of the crisis the
acute phase and then we would support
the
expansion when it came well it's here
and
it's well along and so that's why we
changed our guidance today and we do
have the flexibility to do more when we
think it's appropriate
thank you
thank you gina
hi cheryl thank you for your question
new york times
i was wondering you beefed up your
language on financial stability in the
long run statement that you unveiled
with your jackson hole speech last month
um i'm wondering if you could kind of
walk us through how you think about
financial stability concerns as a factor
in guiding
interpret increases you know would
financial stability concerns on their
own be enough to merit changes in the
fed funds rate
or they have to come in conjunction with
an overheating on
inflation or some sort of dramatic drop
the unemployment rate if you could just
sort of uh give us an outline that we're
thinking there please
so what we said in our statement on
longer-run goals
and uh monetary policy strategy was
uh that the committee's policy decisions
reflect its longer-run goals its
medium-term outlook and its assessment
of the balance of risks
including risks to the financial system
that could impede the attainment of the
committee's goals
uh so that's uh what we said about
financial stability
um and today we said that we'd be
prepared to adjust the stance of
monetary policy as appropriate if risks
emerge that could impede the attainment
of our goals
uh but you asked specifically about
about financial stability um
one thing i would say is that financials
that
monetary policy should not be the first
line of defense is not the first line of
defense on financial stability
we look to more appropriate tools
in the first instance as a first line of
defense and those would be
regulation supervision high capital high
liquidity stress testing
all of those things macro prudential
tools all of those things
are are really the first line of defense
on financial stability but we
we always leave open the idea that we
will not
ignore those kinds of risks and other
kinds of risks more broadly
um that could uh impede the attainment
of our goals
uh in in setting monetary policy so
that's that's really
um how we think about it um but
principally that
other tools are the front line as i
mentioned
but just to follow up quickly if if
other tools aren't worth coming
would financial stability concerns in
and of themselves be enough to warn a
rate hike
so it's you know what we said and again
what we said in the longer run in
our consensus statement is that we you
know
policy decisions reflect uh the balance
of risks including risks to the
financial system that could impede the
attainment of the committee's goal so
the test would be
you know does a majority of the
committee feel that uh that
monetary policy is is triggering that
and that that would be uh that would be
the test
and uh you know it's not something that
we've done we do monitor financial
stability concerns of course
uh intensely and regularly uh we try to
use our other tools on them but we we do
keep them in mind as we think about
monetary policy
thank you steve policemen
mr chairman i wonder if you could help
me understand how um
the projections of the committee line up
with the goals of the committee you've
now
altered the uh projections to uh
the statement to aim for inflation above
two percent
but when i look at the scp
i don't see the committee believe a
single year
in the next four years that you are ever
above two percent in fact for each year
you're below it until 2023 was the first
time
that you actually hit two percent so do
you
think are you confident is this just the
committee is not
confident that not only can it hit its
two percent goal
but that now it can't hit its goal of
being above two percent
not at all and you know you don't you
also don't see people
by and large lifting off or raising
interest rates above zero
i guess there are four exceptions out of
a committee of 17 uh
during that during the forecast period
so we don't reach two percent but we get
very close to it in the forecast
um we reach two percent i guess the
median percent at the end of 2023.
so the you know you know what the
guidance says it says that we expect
that the current setting of our rates
will be what we expect that it will be
appropriate
uh until such time as we reach two
percent inflation
that we feel that labor market
conditions are consistent with our
assessment of maximum employment and
that we're on track
to achieve moderate inflation moderately
above so that's the test so that i don't
think there's any conflict between those
two because
you know the the way they're set up the
projections don't show the out
years you ask your confidence um
and i i would say that this this very
strong very powerful
guidance shows both our confidence and
our determination it shows our
confidence that we can reach this goal
and our determination to do so
i'm sorry if i could just follow up
without being simplistic about this but
why wouldn't
if the committee was confident that it
could reach its new goal of aiming for
inflation above two percent
why wouldn't one of those years at least
show inflation being above two percent
on the median forecast because it uh we
think looking at
everything we know about inflation
dynamics in the united states and around
the world over recent decades
we expect it will take some time we
expect that the economy will
recover quickly now but that that pace
will slow
as uh as people go back to work and
we'll still have an area of the economy
a big area of the economy that struggles
there'll be slack in the economy uh the
economy will be below
maximum employment below full demand and
that will tend to where
put to put downward pressure on
inflation so we think that once we get
up
get up closer to maximum employment we
think that inflation will come back
generally and i mean that's that's sort
of what happened during the last
long expansion it's a slow process but
but there is a process there inflation
does move up over time
we do expect that will continue today
and we expect that our guidance
is powerful and will help that outcome
we think that that
effectively saying that policy will
remain highly accommodative until the
economy is
very far along and its recovery should
provide strong support for the economy
and get us there sooner rather than
later
thank you thank you rachel siegel
hi chair powell thanks very much for
taking my question i wanted to ask if
you
anticipate a slowing in the pace of the
recovery if there is not another
stimulus package
and specifically if there are particular
holes still remaining in the economy
that you think could be helped
by more a from congress thanks very much
sure so um first if you look at the
summary of economic projections that my
colleagues and i
uh filed for this meeting what you'll
see
is an expectation that the recovery will
continue
uh that it will continue at a reasonable
pace through 2021 22 and 23.
we do expect that that pace will slow
just because
you would expect that the pace would be
fastest
right at the beginning of the um right
at the beginning of the recovery because
you had such a sharp decline you would
expect that the third quarter should be
the the fastest gains and then after
that the pace should slow down to a more
normal pace so
we do expect that um in terms of fiscal
policy you ask about fiscal policy so
um uh you know one thing i guess i would
start
by saying that um the initial response
from fiscal authorities
um was rapid it was forceful and pretty
effective
and we're seeing the results of that in
today in the income and household
spending data
in the labor market data in the
construction data in the data for
business equipment spending and the fact
that businesses are are staying in
business
and you know the pace of defaults and
things like that has really slowed
so it's there's been a really positive
effect
that said my sense is that more fiscal
support is likely to be needed
of course the details are that for or
for congress not for the fed
but i would just say there are still
roughly 11 million people
still out of work due to the pandemic
and a good part of those people
were working in industries that are
likely to struggle
those people may need additional
additional support as they try to find
their way
and through what will be a difficult
time for them we've also got
struggling small businesses especially
those in the business of facing
directly to the public and we have state
and local governments dealing with a
drop in revenue at the same time
spending has gone up much of it related
to the pandemic and economic effects
so again i would say the fiscal support
has been essential
in in the good progress we see now and
finally i'll i'll note that
uh just about all the overwhelming
majority of of private forecasters who
project an ongoing
recovery are assuming there will be a
substantial additional
fiscal support
thank you mike derby
taking a question um should we expect
any
further evolutions in forward guidance
uh
say maybe um an adoption of something
akin to the evans rule that we had a few
years ago
or is there something else that the fed
might be considering in the future
well so we think that the forward
guidance we adopted today
is um appropriate and uh
as i mentioned powerful uh effectively
what it says
is that we'll we we will keep policy
where it is now
keep the rate policy where it is now
until
unemployment reaches uh uh the
committee's assessments or
levels that are sorry not unemployment
labor market conditions uh reach levels
that are consistent
with the committee's assessments of
maximum employment until inflation
reaches two percent
and until it's on track to go uh above
two percent
uh moderately for some time so that's
very strong forward guidance and we
think that that will be uh durable
uh guidance that will provide
significant support to the economy in
coming years so that's what that's
really
our thinking on uh on forward guidance
on rates
thank you howard schneider
uh thanks sir uh thanks jeff all for
doing this uh sort of follow up on
mike's question there since you uh
described this guidance as durable
you've set up a three-part test here for
rate hikes uh
levels consistent with uh assessments of
maximum employment
uh inflation has risen to two percent
and you're on track to moderately exceed
two percent for some time
each of these have modifiers and i
wanted to explain a little bit more
um how do we pin down assessments of
maximum employment
uh when you say that inflation has risen
to two percent does that mean
two percent for a day a month six months
uh and when you say on track
to moderately exceed how should we
define moderately
and how should we decline for some time
so as you know
maximum employment is not a it's not
something that can be reduced to a
number the way inflation can it
it's a broad range of factors it really
always has been
and uh really substantial number of
factors that we've
indicated we would look at so it's
broader labor conditions
uh consistent with our committee's
assessment of
maximum employment so that would
certainly mean low unemployment it would
mean high labor force participation it
would mean wages it would be
a whole range of things and we're not
looking at a rule we're looking at a
judgmental assessment which i think
we'll be very transparent about as we
as we go forward um in terms of
inflation
you know this is a committee that is uh
both confident
and committed to um
and determined to reach our goals
and uh the idea that we would look for
the quickest way out is just it's just
not who we are not that there's no
message
of that here we would not be looking for
one month of
two percent inflation we said return to
to achieve two percent inflation okay so
just understand that we you know we're
strongly committed to achieving our
goals and the overshoot so
that should tell you about that um
oh in terms of okay in terms of so what
is it uh moderate means it means not
large it doesn't it means not
very high above two percent it means
moderate i think that's a
fairly well understood work in terms of
in terms of for a time what it means is
not not permanently
and not for a sustained period you know
we're resisting um
the urge to try to create some sort of a
rule or
a formula here and i think that the
public will
understand pretty well what we want it's
it's actually pretty straightforward we
want to achieve inflation that averages
two percent
over time and if we do that inflation
expectations will be right at two
percent and that'll help us achieve two
percent inflation over time and avoid
the situation
where the central bank loses its ability
to support the economy
thank you james politi
uh thanks for taking the question james
pulido with the financial times
um do you consider um today's
enhanced forward guidance to
actual accommodation to the uh to the
u.s economy from a monetary perspective
um and sort of delivered further support
um for the economy or is it just a tweak
to your existing policy stance
um and in terms of fiscal support
uh do you assume in your own projections
not just
uh you know private forecasters um that
additional uh fiscal support will be
forthcoming
or do you expect a weaker growth or
or a larger contraction rather this year
if no fiscal support is forthcoming
so in terms of the effects um so i think
what we've done
is
is more or less aligned with the
consensus statement
uh today so um it's it's in line with
what what might have been expected i
as i mentioned i think over time it will
provide very powerful
support for this economy as we move
forward
uh in a sense it's consistent with
expectations so i don't i'm
not looking for a big reaction right now
but i think over time
again uh guidance that we expect to
retain the current stance
until the economy is has moved very far
toward our goals is a strong and
powerful thing
and i think that will be supportive of
the economy over time
in terms of additional fiscal support
um i guess your question is
uh what would happen if so um
people have different assessments and
different participants in the fomc made
different assessments on their own
i think broadly though there is an
expectation among private forecasters
and among uh fomc participants that
there will be some
further fiscal action and there does
seem to be an appetite
on the part of all the relevant players
to doing something the question is how
much and
when and so i would just say that if um
and it's very hard to say that so
so far the economy has proven resilient
to the
to the lapsing of the um to the the
cares act unemployment
um enhanced unemployment benefits but
there's there's certainly a risk though
that um
that those who are unemployed have saved
appear to have saved some of those
benefits and they'll they'll now spend
them
and that as the months pass if if
there's no follow-up on that if there
isn't
additional support and there isn't a job
for the some of those people or from
industries where it's going to be very
hard to find new work
then you'll that will start to show up
in economic activity it'll also
show up in things like evictions and
foreclosures
and uh and you know things that will
scar and damage the economy so
that's a downside risk so i i think the
real question is
is when and how much and what will be
the what will be the contents
and you know no one no one has any
certainty around that but
broadly speaking uh if we don't get that
then there would certainly be downside
risks through certainly through the
channel i mentioned
you anakin cnn thanks for taking my
question
um give us a recent update to the policy
framework and repeated calls for this in
the fed lessons event
is the fed open to other measures of the
economy such as income inequality and
affordability of housing
so we you know we monitor
everything we think is important in the
us economy and in that in a broad sense
all of it goes into thinking about
monetary policy you mentioned inequality
so you know disparities in in
um in income and in well in financial
well-being
by various demographic and racial
categories something we monitor
carefully
inequality which i would i would point
to it's a multi-faceted thing but i
would point to the relative stagnation
of incomes for people at the lower end
of the income spectrum
and also lower mobility so those are
things
that hold back our economy they are
the thing is we don't really have the
tools to address those we we have
interest rates and bank supervision and
financial stability policy and things
like that but
um we can't we can't get at those things
through our tools when we
lower the federal funds rate that
supports the economy across a broad
range
of of people and activities but we can't
we don't have the ability to target
particular
groups um notwithstanding that we we do
talk about it because these are
important features of our economy and we
you know i think those are
those distributional issues are are
issues that are really for our elected
officials
and i would say i i take them seriously
as holding back
our economy the productive capacity of
the economy is limited
when not everyone has the opportunity
has the educational background
uh and and and the health care and all
the things that you need
to be an active participant in our
workforce
so i think we can if we want to have the
the
the highest potential output and the
best output for our economy we need that
prosperity to be very broadly
spread um in the longer run and i
again i would just say the fed you know
we can talk about those things a lot and
and in
in when we think about maximum
employment in particular we do look at
individual groups so
the the high unemployment in a
particular
racial group like african americans when
you know we would look at that as we
think about whether we're really at
maximum employment we would look
we would look at that along with a lot
of other data so
the answer is we do look at all those
things and and do what we can with our
tools but ultimately
these are issues for elected
representatives
thank you edward lawrence yeah thank you
chairman powell for the question um i
just wanted some clarity here at what
point do you think it's prudent
to shift the bond purchases from uh
market stability as you would said from
the shorter term maturities to more
longer term more stimulus related
so you know we think our we think that
our asset purchases are doing both
things both those things today we think
clearly there's been
great progress in terms of market
function if you remember early in the
spring when the acute phase of the
pandemic hit the
market function was very low and it's
improved rapidly and in many respects is
is in a good place now we also though
think that these asset purchases which
total 120 billion a month you know which
is
much larger than uh than for example the
last uh
asset purchase program during the global
financial crisis and the recovery
they're from
um we think that that's also providing
accommodate financial conditions and
supporting growth and we think that's
fine we're also aware that we there are
ways we can adjust that
um you know to do various things and you
know make it smaller make it larger
and also target different sectors of the
um of the
of the uh of the curve and you know
we're
we're gonna continue to monitor
developments and we're prepared to
adjust our plans as appropriate
thank you victoria
victoria guida hi thanks for taking my
question um
i wanted to ask you about a couple of
things first of all um
if we don't get a vaccine until well
into next year what does that mean for
the economy
and then um somewhat related i was
wondering if you could provide any more
detail
about the stress scenarios that you all
are going to release for the big banks
and whether that is going to be another
full-blown stress test
whether we're going to publicly see
those results and what it might mean for
bank payouts great so on the first one
um
what's happening is basically we're
learning to live with
right now we're learning to live with
covid which still spreads
and we're learning to to engage in
economic activity
all of this recovery that we've seen is
in a context where
um you know where people are still at
risk of of
of catching it and yet we're able to
resume
lots and lots of economic activities and
um
that involves as i mentioned you know i
think the more
social distancing we can preserve as we
go back into the workforce
wearing masks keeping our distance that
kind of thing the better we'll be able
to
get economic activity back up close to
where it was
i do think though there are areas of the
economy that are just going to really
struggle
until we have a vaccine that's that's um
that's in wide
uh you know wide usage and is is widely
trusted and those are the ones where
people are getting really closely to
close together
i also think testing to the extent you
have cheap
and rapid testing you can do a lot with
that
in the workforce you can you can build
confidence in the workforce if you have
regular very regular testing it doesn't
cost very much and you get the results
really quickly
if you do that you'll be able to open a
lot of work forces
particularly in cities where the overall
case numbers are quite low
and that will help a lot so i think
we're going to be finding lots and lots
of ways to get out towards
you know as far as we can there's always
going to be that for for some time
there's going to be certain activities
that will be
that will be hard to re to resume so i i
think that's the only way
i can say it and i think trying to you
know we all when we make a forecast we
we make assessments about that but
it's really hard to say there's no
template here there's no
um you know there's no experience with
this so
frankly for the last uh 60 days or so
the economy's recovered faster than
expected and
then continue or not we just don't know
and i i think we should do those things
that we
control uh to make sure that we can
recover as quickly as possible and the
main thing again
is wearing a map keeping your distance
while you're in the workforce that's
that's something we can all do that will
limit the spread and
let people go back to work avoid major
outbreaks and things like that
in terms of the stress test so
i really don't have any you know we're
we're getting ready
quite soon to be making announcements
and saying things publicly and there's
not much i can say with you
uh nothing really that i can say that's
uh on that today i don't have anything
for you
thank you chris condon
thank you michelle good afternoon uh
chairman powell
uh you have emphasized many times
including today
that uh the fed can only lend and not
spend and sometimes the latter is what's
really needed but
to the extent that a 600 billion dollar
lending program for small and mid-sized
companies
could help what exactly is wrong
with the design or function of the main
street
lending program which has purchased just
i think 1.4 billion dollars in loans so
far
eric rosen granted the boston federation
recently that
congress should clarify how much risk
it wants the program to take but
congress has already appropriated
substantial funds
for the 13-3 programs these are funds
that are explicitly designed
to absorb losses meanwhile my colleagues
who cover the banking sector say they're
being told
by commercial banks that the treasury
department is advising them to target
zero losses zero losses in main street
program loans so if i may
why is it that the federal reserve the
congress
and the treasury apparently cannot agree
on a loss tolerance that should be
applied to the main street
lending program in a way that would
allow badly needed credit to reach these
companies
thank you sure sir so
a couple things about main street it
reaches the whole nation
and it's got more than half of the
banking industry assets signed up
among the banks that are part of it and
it's making loans the number is more
like it's close to two billion dollars
now so the numbers are going up
uh banks are are joining uh
borrowers are coming
and it's significant it's it's
relatively small now but it can scale up
in response to economic conditions
should that be should that be
appropriate um
you know if you look out in the lending
world um
uh surveys generally find that that
firms are not citing credit constraints
as a top problem and that that is a lot
of ppp
bank credit lines and syndicated loans
there's a lot of credit being
let out there
so but you're right we
we are looking at some things we're
looking at
some lenders are concerned about the
underwriting expectations
so banks are going to their their
approach is
likely to be that they're going to
underwrite this loan roughly the same as
they
write underwrite any loan they're
keeping part of it
and um you know what what we want to do
is make sure that uh that they know that
they should take
uh the payment deferrals and other
things in in place and also that
you know it's it's really a it's really
a
facility for uh for companies or
borrowers
that that don't have access to to
regular way borrowing now otherwise why
would we need main street
um so that's what we're working on
and uh we'll be doing some some uh some
we'll be making some changes in that
respect
i i don't i saw what president rosengren
said i i
can't really comment directly on that i
just would say
um that you know this is 13-3
if you look at the law under section 33
it's very clear
that we are to make loans only to
solvent borrowers and the cares act is
quite specific
in keeping all of the terms of of
section 13 3 in effect
including the requirement that we you
know gather good evidence that the
borrower is solvent
this was this law was amended in you
know under
um uh in dodd-frank and the idea was
was to make it challenging and put
hurdles in place before we made loans
what
at the time the thinking was to bank so
now we
now we're using that same law for for uh
smaller business
borrowers and it you know it doesn't
it's not
a perfect fit and and i i would also
just say for for many borrowers um
they're in a situation where uh where
their business is still relatively shut
down
and they won't be able to serve us alone
and so they may need more fiscal support
um having said that we're continuing to
work to
to improve main street to make it more
broadly available
make it make it make it uh
available pretty much to any company
that needs it then it can serve us alone
could you just very briefly address the
reports that the treasury is advising
banks to target zero losses
is that appropriate i can't say i i
don't i don't know about that i haven't
heard those reports
you know again if you think about it
we we weren't we're we're going to have
to go through the banking system to do
this we we're not going to have 100 000
or a million
loan officers working for the fed in the
treasury so we're going to go through
the banking system
and the banks banks like to make good
loans that's what they do they're
trained to make good loans
so you should expect that they and we
expect that they will do some
underwriting
we also want them to take some risk
obviously because that was the point of
it
and the question is how do you dial that
in it's it's it's not an easy thing to
do and
you know we're we're getting some loans
made and we're hopeful that we'll that
we'll
clarify this and and uh that credit will
continue to flow
thank you chris rue gabriel
hi um thanks for taking my question um
chair powell you've talked a couple of
times about um
parts of the economy that may not
recover as fast as we've seen so far
presumably you're referring to you know
airlines hotels
other um sections you know
parts of the economy that rely on close
contact how are you thinking about that
in terms of its overall impact is that
sector
large enough to say keep unemployment
above
you know far above your maximum goals
are you expecting to come back with a
vaccine or are a lot of those folks
going to have to find
you know new jobs in new industries and
should we expect the fed will keep rates
at zero
until all of that reallocation is done
thank you
yeah we of course we can't be we can't
be really sure we know the answers to
those questions
but i would say the the likely path
is that um the the expansion will
continue
and it's as i said it's well along and
it'll move
most easily through the parts of the
economy uh
it'll still take some time but the parts
of the economy that weren't exactly
directly affected it didn't involve
getting people in large groups together
to feed them to fly them around to put
them in hotels to entertainment things
like that those are going to be the
places that are
that are very challenging so
there will also be the you know the
places that are affected that way and
that's going to be challenging for some
time it just is and we don't really know
how long that will be
it's you know it's millions of people um
as i mentioned we had 11 million
something like 11 million people in the
payroll survey
have gone back to work out of 22 million
uh
who went who who lost their jobs in
march and april so that's half of them
so 11 million
particularly if the pace of returning to
work slows down it's going to leave a
large
a large group of people and it'll be
very meaningful from a macroeconomic
standpoint
and our commitment is not to forget
those people we as i mentioned we we
want
you know the sense of our forward
guidance is that policy will remain as
we've said
highly accommodative until the until the
um
uh expansion is well along
really very close to our goals and even
after if we do lift off
we will keep policy accommodative until
we actually have a
moderate overshoot of inflation for some
time so
those are powerful commitments that we
think will will support
the full recovery including those people
as long as it takes
thank you mike mckee
mr chairman michael mckee from bloomberg
radio and television uh
based on what you were just saying about
keeping policy accommodated for a very
long time
into the recovery um lower for longer
as far out as three years in your latest
projections
is that basically it for the fed in
other words since interest rates are
your main
tool the things you can do would push
down on interest rates
but is it really is it the case now that
the
only additional stimulus that can come
to the economy
is from the fiscal side
well um no i wouldn't i
certainly would not say uh that we're
out of ammo
um not at all um so
first of all we we do have uh
lots of tools we've got the lending
tools we've got the balance sheet
and we've got further forward guidance
further forward guidance so we we
there's still plenty more that we can do
we do think that our that our
our rate policy stance is an appropriate
one to support the economy we think it's
powerful
uh and as i mentioned uh you know this
is
the kind of guidance that will provide
support for the economy over time
the idea being that policy will remain
uh highly accommodative
until the recovery is well along really
very close to our goals and then we'll
remain accommodative
even after we lift off so i think that's
that's a really strong
uh place for uh for rate policy to be
but again we have the other margins that
we can still use so
no certainly we're not out of ammo well
if i could
tell a lot in terms of the balance sheet
are you concerned
that your actions are more likely to
produce
asset price inflation than goods and
such as
inflation in other words uh are you
risking a bubble in
on wall street you know so we of course
we monitor financial conditions very
carefully
um these are these are not uh new
questions these were questions that were
very much in the air a decade ago uh and
more
when uh when the fed first started doing
qe and i would say if you look at the
long experience
of uh you know the 10-year eight month
expansion the longest in our recorded
history
included an awful lot of quantitative
easing and low rates for seven years
and i would say it was notable for the
lack of
the emergence of of some sort of a
financial bubble
a housing bubble or some kind of a
bubble
the popping of which could threaten the
expansion that didn't happen
and frankly it hasn't really happened
around the world since then that doesn't
mean that it won't happen
but and so of course it's something that
we monitor carefully
after the financial crisis we started a
new a whole division of the fed to focus
on financial stability
we look at it in every from every
perspective
the fmc gets briefed on a quarterly
basis at the board here we talk about it
more or less on an ongoing basis so it
is something we monitor but
um i don't know that the uh that the
connection between
uh asset purchases and and financial
stability is a particularly tight one
so uh but again we'll be we won't be
uh we won't be uh just assuming that
we'll be checking carefully
as we go and by the way the the kinds of
tools that we would use
to address those sorts of things are not
really monetary policy it would be more
tools that strengthen the financial
system
thank you don lee mr paul i'd
like to ask you about the labor market
um as you know in august there were
about 30 million persons
claiming unemployment benefits
the bls jobs report for august showed
about 13.5 million
unemployed only about 6 million more
than
before the pandemic i wonder how you
reconcile that
what do you think the tool and labor
market conditions are
so i mean i think the the overall
picture take a step back from this the
overall picture is
clear and that is that the labor market
uh has been recovering but that it's a
long way
a long way for maximum employment i
think that's that's the bottom line on
it
um so within that though uh the take
claims in particular um the the number
of claims the quantity of claims and
frankly the new the fact that that
pua claims are new the pandemic
unemployment assistance claims that's a
new system that had to be set up
um the actual counting of the claims um
is uh is volatile and and it's very
difficult to take
um much signal about the particular
level so
you know because people were setting
those systems up and when they got them
set up they
they counted them all at once and things
like that i think though what you've
seen is that the the level of certainly
the level of initial claims has
has declined very sharply from the very
high levels of march and april
and is now at a lower level uh continues
either to be flat or gradually decline
uh it's worth noting and that's good
it's worth noting that that level is
maybe five times the level of what
claims were claims were around 200
thousand now there are nine hundred
thousand in that range uh
uh weekly for for initial claims so that
just tells you the labor market has
improved but
it's a long long way from maximum
employment and it will be some time
getting back there
i think that's that's the best way to
think about it in many parts of the
economy there's just
a lot of disruption and it's it's really
hard to say precisely
where we are i'll give you another
example with you know you we say
unemployment's 8.4 but if you count
those who
are who are misidentified as
as uh as employed when they're actually
unemployed and you add back
some part of the participation numbers
so if you were you had a job and you
were in the labor force in february and
you lost it because of the pandemic
some of you are now being reported as
out of the labor force but you know i
would i would more look at those people
as unemployed if you add those back
the level of unemployment's probably
three percent higher on the other hand
by that metric the the the unemployment
rate would have been in the in the 20s
in in um in april so the improvement has
been quite substantial
under any measurement but the level is
still quite high
well if i could follow if is it the
fed's aim to get back to 3.5
or even lower yes absolutely
you know i i can't be precise about a
particular number
but let me just say there was a lot to
like about three and a half percent on
the play
it's not a magic number no no one would
say that number is the touchstone
and or that is you know maximum
employment i would just say you ask
about three and a half percent
a three and a half percent uh
unemployment rate
showed uh you know gains being shared
very widely across the income spectrum
in fact going more to people at the
bottom end of the spectrum it showed
labor force participation coming
up as up above many estimates of its
trend as people who'd been out of the
labor force were being
pulled into a tight job market there's a
lot to like about a
tough tight job market particularly in a
world where we didn't see
inflation so yes we'd love to get back
to that i mean i'd say
we would like to get back rather than to
a particular number we'd
like to get back to a strong labor
market
where wages are moving up where people
can find work
where labor force participation is
holding up nicely
uh that's what we really love to get
back to now of course we would
we need inflation to perform in line
with with
um with our our framework uh but um the
good news is
uh we think we can have quite low
unemployment without raising troubling
inflation
thank you nancy marshall ginzer
hi nancy marshall genser marketplace uh
chair paul i want to follow up on the
wealth gap issue i know you were saying
that you have limited tools
but are there things that you can do
possibly in the area of research and
maybe expand your research on racial
economic gaps
you know we do one
we are gifted with a um a substantial
group of researchers that who really
cover
the waterfront and we do a significant
amount of research
on racial disparities in across
multiple variables including wealth as
you ask about
so we do that and we also remember we
have our
division of consumer and community
affairs which is present in communities
around the country and the reserve banks
all have very active community affairs
groups
they're presented they're present in
communities around the country so
uh it wasn't just the fed fed listens
events
it's more just over a long period of
time we
are in contact with people in those
communities to understand their
experience of the economy
we serve all americans and we know that
and we're going to use our tools
to to reflect that fact so the answer is
yes we
we do quite a bit of research and i
suppose we could do more but we really
do a lot and we contribute to those
fields and those assessments of uh
of of the state of the economy and we do
that not just because it's uh
interesting and important but because
it's important for the economy and
important for our mandate
we are assigned maximum employment now
what does that mean
as i mentioned earlier it doesn't mean a
particular
headline unemployment number what it
means is
maximum employment so you know we look
at we look at that in many many
different variables
and we ask ourselves whether those
variables or
or those labor market conditions are
consistent with our assessments of what
would constitute
maximum employment and that would
include all of the things that we're
talking about
thank you greg rob
hi craig from marketwatch thanks for
this
i want to go back to the new forward
guidance that you have
and you say that it's powerful but it
it you've already have two dissent two
dissenting voters on it
and um i was wondering if there's other
other people argued against it and and
what do you say to the two who descended
it looks like president kash khari
wanted a simpler
for guidance and president kaplan
thought that the current
guide to have was fine for now so like
how did you argue back
on those on those arguments thank you
i wouldn't um i don't want to comment
particularly on on
on the two dissenters but they consent
they they descended from of course
different perspectives and
and that should be clear that's they're
they're they're not they're sort of on
on two sides uh of the discussion but i
would say this i i am blessed with
having a committee of highly thoughtful
people who bring
diverse life experiences and diverse
careers and of course diverse views to
our work
and i wouldn't have it any other way i
wouldn't so
so i would just say the
right acro in our discussions uh the
last couple of days
the whole committee everybody on the
committee is very supportive
of the statement on long-run goals and
monetary policy strategy and and what's
in there
very very broad support unanimous
support for that
everyone sees the the changes in the
underlying economy and seas in their own
way
um the need to address those and
including the changes we made to the
employment mandate and
to uh inflation so that we're now a
flexible average inflation target
of course there would be this is we're
you know we're the first
major central bank to adopt this
framework um
there's no cookbook uh and we
you know this is the first guidance
under our new framework so of course
there would be a wide range of views and
you would expect that
and it's actually a healthy thing so i
welcome that discussion
i would also say this you know this is
all about credibility and we understand
perfectly that we have to
earn credibility this this facility this
this framework has to
we have to support it with our actions
and i think today is a very good
first step in doing that it is a strong
powerful guidance it is it ties in very
nicely with
the statement of long-run goals and
monetary policy strategy
we had quite a robust discussion there
there are different ideas on how to do
this but
um i i that's just that's just the way
it is when you have a
diverse group of highly thoughtful and
effective people
and um so i'm pleased with where it came
out
thank you hannah lang
hi chair powell thanks so much for
to ask about watching commercial real
estate uh i
i know you wouldn't mention people
weren't sure if there was a way the fed
could support
cre borrowers but i was just wondering
if you have if you've had any other
continued discussions on that
uh and if there's any uh potential that
could step
in in that area so thank you for that
question
you know we've actually spent quite a
bit of time
on this as secretary mnuchin i think
mentioned the other day
and i'll say just a couple things first
you know
our facilities are essentially always
they have to be under the law
broad-based and not so much targeting
any single sector
um also it's important to remember that
cre commercial real estate
benefits from several of our existing
facilities so the talf
takes commercial mortgage-backed
securities and sba
commercial real estate deals and the new
york fed purchases
agency cms bss directly in
addition i would say uh main street uh
helps um uh businesses pay their rent
you know so so we're we're helping real
estate
um you know in a number of other ways
commercial real estate
also cmbs issuance has resumed spreads
have tightened on cnbs
um the the couple of issues one is just
that commercial properties with cmbs
loans often have covenants uniformly i
think have covenants that forbid them to
take on more debt
so you have a situation and you have a
situation
where where you without a legal change
or some kind of an innovation
that defies discoveries so far you
you're you have a hard time providing
mass relief with regard to
real estate that's in in commercial
mortgage-backed securities
so we're still working on it we're still
looking i i would say it may be that
further support for
commercial real estate will require
further action for congress from
congress
for the last question we'll go to brian
chung
hi chairman powell so uh it seems like a
lot of the new inflation framework
is about shaping inflation expectations
but the average american that might be
watching this might be confused as to
why the fed is overshooting the
inflation so what's your explanation to
main street to
average people what the fed is trying to
do here and uh what the
outcome would be for those on nature yes
it's very very important question and i
actually spoke about that in my jackson
hole remarks a couple weeks ago
it's not intuitive to people it is
intuitive that high inflation is a bad
thing it's less intuitive that
inflation can be too low and the way i
would explain it is is that
inflation that's too low will mean that
interest rates are lower
there's an expectation of future
inflation that's built into every
interest rate
right and to the extent inflation gets
lower and lower and lower interest rates
get lower and lower and then the fed
will have
less room to cut rates to support the
economy and this isn't some
idle you know uh academic theory this is
what's happening
all over the world if you if you look at
many many large jurisdictions around the
world
you are seeing that phenomenon so we
want inflation to be
we want it to be two percent and and we
want it to average two percent so if
inflation averages two percent
the public will expect that and that'll
be what's built into interest rates and
that's just that's all we want so we're
not looking
to have high inflation we just want
inflation to average two percent
and that means that you know in a
downturn
these days what happens is inflation as
is happen now it moves down
well below two percent and that means
that we've said for
for we would we would like to see and we
will conduct policies so that
uh inflation moves for some time
moderately above two percent so it won't
be these won't be large overshoots and
they won't be permanent but
to help anchor inflation expectations at
two percent
um so yes it's uh it's
it's uh it's a challenging concept for a
lot of people but nonetheless
the economic importance of it is is is
large
and uh you know those are the people
we're serving and
uh you know we we serve them best if we
can actually achieve average two percent
inflation we believe and that's why we
changed our framework
thank you thanks very much
[Music]
you